That there's no warrant for that
from the psychological community.
So anyways, I got up at two in the
morning and made these videos. I thought,
well, let's see what happens if I
make these videos. It's like, well,
this is back to the technology issue.
It's like I didn't know what YouTube
was when I put my videos on it.
You didn't know what YouTube
was. Well, you know what I,
no one knows what YouTube is.
That would be the thing. Well,
look at what happened to
you. You have a million,
billion and a half downloads a year.
It's like you're definitely
riding a giant wave.
Like would have you predicted
this 15 years ago? No. So,
so you know you're in the right place
in the right time and you're a very
interesting interviewer because
while, especially for long form,
because you're very, very curious,
but also very, very tough.
Like it's interesting watching you
because if you don't understand something,
you will go after the person and you're
not doing it in a vindictive way,
but you're quite formidable interviewer.
And I've been trying to figure
out why you're so successful.
And like you're a lot smarter
than anyone might think,
which is quite interesting.
So you're a weird combination because
you know your persona doesn't shout
intellectual,
but you're damn smart and you're tough
as a bloody boat and you ask really pop
provocative questions and not because
you're provocative and so your personality
in this long form seem to
suit each other really well.
You're also really good at pursuing
things you don't understand instead of
assuming that you know
what you're talking about.
So you take the listeners on a journey,
right? It's an exploratory journey,
but fundamentally what's propelled you
to superstardom in some sense is not just
your ability, which is nontrivial,
but the fact that you're on this giant
technological wave and you're one of the
first adopters. And I'm
in the same situation.
We're first adopters of technology.
That's as revolutionary as
the Gutenberg printing press.
And so that's all unfolding in real time.
It's like, look at what's happening.
Yeah, well the spoken word is now
as powerful as the written word.
That's never happened
before in human history.
And we're on the cutting edge
of that for better or worse.
That's a very good way to put it.
The spoken word is just power. Yeah.
And maybe even more so. Well,
he's so accessible to people that don't
have the time to read well or stuck in
traffic or, or, and here's
another possibility,
maybe 10 times as many people can listen
to complex information as can read
complex information in terms
of their ability to process it.
Sure could easily, we don't know.
Maybe it's, maybe it's the same.
Certainly easier to listen to a book on
tape for me than it is to read a book.
Yeah. Well, so for us, so the question
is for how many people is that true?
And I would say it might be true for
them, for the majority of people.
And then people are
doing hybrids, you know,
so because you can sync your
book with audible, right.
So they'll read when they have the time,
but then when they have found time,
which is also a major component of this,
that that's the time when you're driving
or the time when you're doing dishes is
now all of a sudden you can educate
yourself during that found time.
This is a big revolution and the
blowing out the bandwidth makes a huge
difference because while we talked
about that at the beginning,
looks like people are more
intelligent than we thought.
And you and I are both in the
rest of this intellectual web.
That's kind of what unites us say is
everybody has an independent platform.
Virtually everybody, they have
an idiosyncratic viewpoint.
They're interested in having discussions
and pursuing the furtherance of their
knowledge, even though they might
have a priori ideological commitments.
Sam does. And I suppose I do, and
and Ben Shapiro certainly does,
but they're still interested in having
the discussion. But more importantly,
they're capitalizing on the long form.
And the fact that that's possible is
a reflection of this technological
transformation and the technological
transformation might be utterly profound.
It looks like it. And so that's, you know,
I've been trying to sort this
out because I keep thinking,
why the hell are these people coming to
listen to what I'm saying? It's like,
well I'm a guru. You know, I'm a
Sage. It's something like that.
It's like don't be thinking that first.
Think if there's situational
determinants first.
Take your damn personality out of
it. Okay. What's going on? Oh yes.
This is all fostered by YouTube
and fostered by podcasts.
What's so new about that?
No bandwidth restrictions,
no barrier to entrance,
possibility of dialogue because people
cut up the YouTube videos into chunks and
make their own comments on. It's a
whole new communication technology.
Also a lack of interference by executives
and producers and all these different
people that have their own bias.
Yeah. So unmediated as giant. Yeah.
Yeah. Well and that's all part.
Part of the reason you're so popular
too is like you just put this on like,
so you've got exactly the right
balance of ah, competent production.
Cause there's nothing access
about it. Like it's competent,
but no more than that. I know that's
by design, but you also don't edit it.
It's like what you see is what you get.
It's like everyone's relieved by that.
We could make our own damn decisions
do. I think that's very important.
If you're going to have a conversation
with someone that's honest,
you can't decide what to leave in
and what to take out and it's just,
well, that's partly also why I
deal with the press the way I do.
If I'm going to have a full conversation,
it's like I'm willing to take the hits and
I understand what you're saying,
but that's one of the reasons why it
frustrates me so much is that I see what
they're doing and I'm like,
what you're doing is ancient.
What you're doing is it's, it's,
this is what people did 20 years ago,
30 years ago. You can't really do that
anymore. You can't misrepresent people.
You used to be able to,
if you were in the press,
you could take people quote amount of
context, do whatever the fuck you wanted,
put an article about them and they
couldn't do a God damn thing about it.
It happened to me in 19. Boy,
it was like 99. I did a,
a con I had a comedy CD that came out
and this woman wrote an article about it
and it just, she just lied.
She lied about my perspective.
She lied about the bits.
She misquoted the bits.
She didn't just paraphrase them.
She changed what the bits
were to make them, you know,
massage NIST or hateful
or whatever it was.
And in doing so, I, there was no recourse.
There was nothing that I could
do about that. I'm like, wow,
I'd never experienced that
before. I like, this is stunning.
And then I found out this person did
that a lot and this is what she did.
And there's ultimate power that comes
with being the person who has the pen and
being the person who has
the typewriter and you, you,
you're the person who works for, you know,
the Boston globe or whatever the
publication is that that is, uh,
something that existed forever, you know,
and that you had to be either a friend
of the press, you had to play ball,
you had to, you had a bend to their will.
You had to do what they wanted you to do,
and they could misrepresent you and
choose to paint you in any way they like.
And it's one of the reasons why
I don't do anything anymore.
I don't do any interviews
anymore. I don't do anything.
I don't want to do anything because I do
enough. Man, you want to know about me?
It fucking, there's a thousand podcasts.
There's more than a thousand. There's,
I think there's, there's 1100 and
there's a bunch of other ones too. Right.
Let's just, it's, it
doesn't make any sense.
Yeah. Well that, that, that,
that it may also be the position
that I increasingly find myself in.
I think it's the right position because
then the misrepresentations don't exist
anymore. So then the only problem is
the dispute over the actual ideological
conversations or the, the,
the, the actual concept.
But you know, the thing is, you know,
you made a point there that's quite
interesting is like we are in a new media
landscape. So now if
someone comes out as a,
as a media figure with some institutional
credibility and misrepresents,
it's exposed.
And so then the question is how much
risk should you shoulder to expose the
proclivity for media misrepresentation?
And the answer to that might be some
now it might be moving, you know,
maybe I've done enough of that.
I mean it would be easier for me in many
ways if I just stopped doing it. But,
but there's some utility in
having it play out. And so while,
so I'm trying to, I'm,
I'm trying to only take
those opportunities that
appear to have more benefit
than risk. And when I defining benefit,
well the question is then
what constitutes benefit?
And I guess what constitutes benefit is
while that would further the attempts
that I making to bring information
to a vast number of people that could
conceivably help them stabilize
and improve their individual lives,
that's worth a certain amount of risk.
Well it certainly increases your
profile, increases your profile.
And even if you know you have 60% of
these people are going to get a bad
perception of you, 40% of these
people that never heard of you,
now we're going to understand who you are
because they do further investigation.
Yeah. So there's some benefit in
that. But the negative, I mean I've,
I get text messages from random people
that I was friends with years ago.
They'd say this Jordan Peterson is just
such a lying sack of shit and he's this
now. Like I don't even know who the fuck
you are. And then second of all like,
why are you contacting me?
You're not even saying hi.
You're saying Jordan
Peterson is a, is a this,
he's a scam artist. He's a fraud.
He's at the end. I'm like wow.
And so they'll see an interview, you
know like the, the Jim Jefferies clip,
which is a minute long, or it is,
or the vice piece or the initial Cathy
Newman piece and they just form this
determined position on you and
then read hit pieces on you.
And then this is where they take their
opinion of this is where it's from and
it's, I,
I feel like these are the last gasps
of a dying medium. I really do. I just,
I think too, I don't, I don't
think that people appreciate it.
I think the people that are listening
to this that do appreciate long form
conversations and with all warts and all,
all the ugliness and the mistakes and
the critical errors and the people that
appreciate that they, they,
they have a real hate for being
lied to. You know, because it's, it,
it changed when,
when you for being treated as if
they're stupid, which they aren't.
Yeah, that's both. It's just, it's,
it's deceptive when you,
when you edit someone and take their
words out of context and change them
around, you're being deceptive.
Didn't. The New York times
did that again this week.
They had some philosophy professor from
Hong Kong university write a piece on me
and he took, they quoted
me a was a sentence.
There's like the first phrase was in
quotes and then there were some joining
words and then the second phrase was in
quotes and there were some joining words
and then the third phrase was in quotes
and the three quotes added up to a
statement that bore no
resemblance whatsoever to what
I was saying. How can they
do that in the New York times?
That seems to me to be something
that should be the the,
I don't think they can, I
don't think they can do,
I think they're killing their brand
so fast that they, that they can't,
but it's so disturbing to me as a person
who's been a fan of the New York times
forever. I just don't understand
how they could allow that to happen.
How could you allow your, what? What is
gold standard for journalism?
How could you allow it to become something
that willfully misrepresent someone?
Well, they never did to push an idea.
It never did put my book on the
New York times bestseller list,
which quite comical. How's that
possible? Oh, they have rules,
which they don't disclose, but
one of them apparently is, well,
if the book is published in Canada
and distributed in the United States,
then it doesn't count.
Even though they've had books like that
on the New York times bestseller list
before. And I think, okay, well is
this bad or good? It's like, well,
it's bad because to the degree that I
might want to be on the New York times
bestseller list, although I
haven't been losing any sleep over,
but you're selling, I know how
many books are selling. Yeah.
It's basically been the best selling book
in the world since January. You know,
it's gone up and down to some degree,
but fundamentally it should be the number
one New York times bestselling book.
So they, they, they, they
have their reasons and,
but I look at that and I think, Oh,
well you can only do that 10
times until you're done. Like,
because it's a fatal error. You have
the gold standard for measurement.
You're not measuring properly, you're
burning up your brand. You think,
well we're the New York times so we
can burn up our brand. It's like,
no you can't. Newsweek is gone.
Time magazine is a shallow sh
is a shell of its former self.
Like the big things disappear and they
disappear when they get crooked and
ideologically rigid.
And so that's what's happening at the New
York times and not with everyone there
but with plenty of them. And it'll
die faster than people think.
But it's so confusing to me
that he didn't use to be that.
Yup. And now it is.
And they just responding to this new
world where you have to have clickbait
journalism and you know,
some of people are struggling to find
people to actual biophysical newspapers,
which is two different things.
Hard to say because maybe, see,
it's weird because you don't
have to resort to clickbait
because these long form
discussions are the antithesis
of clickbait, right.
That are they struggling in terms of
like how many people buy their newspaper?
Oh absolutely. Every newspaper,
the newspapers in Canada went cap in
hand to the federal government for
subsidies.
About six months ago because they're
dying so fast and so some of it is they're
being supplanted by technology.
That's a huge part of it.
But as they are supplanted,
they get more desperate.
They publish more polarizing stories that
works in the short term to garner more
views. But it alienates people from
the brand and speeds their demise.
Classic death spiral of a
big of a big organization.
And that's going to clean
things out like mad.
I mean I don't know where CNN is in the
cable news rankings now our cable show
rankings but it keeps falling but it's
falling in the rankings as cable itself
disintegrates and dies. Why
do you need cable TV, right?
No one needs cable T the only people
who have cable TV are the people who fig
haven't figured out yet that you can
replace it entirely online for like one
10th the price with with much less hassle.
But the IRA is people want a location
they can go to to find out what's going on
in the world. And this is the one
thing that they used to represent.
And you know, I mean, I don't
think Fox news is any better.
I think you just have these
ideological extremes left and right.
And I remember very clearly watching the
election coverage before the election,
like leading up to the election, I would
go Fox news and then I'd go see an end.
I just would go back and forth of them
on my cable and I would just be laughing.
I'm be like, what is really
happening in the world?
Because I'm getting two different stories.
I'm getting Russia and I'm getting
Hillary's emails. This is, I mean,
I don't know what the fuck
is, what, what is happening?
I'm getting pussy grabbing
and I'm getting, you know, uh,
Bengazi I'm,
this is what I'm getting and I don't
understand like why this is obviously
ideological, this is not just,
it might be that as the
technology is supplanted,
the ideological polarization
increases as the thing dies, right?
They're struggling for
anyone to pay attention.
And this is the way they
have to do it to ensure,
and I think what's happening on the
other side, which is the side you occupy,
say,
is that a new technology that's long form
that deals with many of those problems
is emerging and it's going to
emerge. It's going to be victorious.
But in the mean might already
be victorious in the meantime,
baby stuff still exist in
the digital world. You know,
and then you're getting a lot of the
articles that are written about you.
People are absorbing these
articles, not from a physical form.
You're getting it from, from digital
yet. Well, okay, so then the sense is,
well, do you have fundamental trust
in the judgment of your fellow man,
let's say? And my answer to that is yes,
because although I've been pilloried to
a great degree by the radical types in
the commentary at, in, in, in
the classic journalists, um,
though comments with regards to me
on YouTube are 50 to one in my favor.
And, and that's even the case when
the ideologues put up videos about me.
They're designed to discredit me, and
I've sold a million and a half books.
It's going to be
published in 40 countries,
and thousands of people
are coming to my lectures.
And so I would say the attempts
to discredit me aren't working.